From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. So you've heard, right? The US State Department has hired a former ad executive to run an information campaign to make the United States more beloved in the Muslim world.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，正在为您播出由国际公共广播电台发行的《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。你们都听说了吧？美国国务院聘请了一位前广告公司高管，负责开展一场信息宣传活动，旨在提升美国在穆斯林世界的好感度。
We know that in many of the countries where our messages are sent that often they're distorted, they're one-dimensional, or they're simply not heard.
我们知道，在我们投放信息的许多国家，这些信息往往被扭曲、被片面化，或者根本无人理会。
This is Charlotte Beers, formerly of Madison Avenue, whose taken what is certainly a colossal pay cut to become undersecretary of state in charge of this effort. And while many of the things that she's announced so far are eminently sensible-- better communication with foreign journalists, exchange programs so more people from the Muslim world get to meet and know real Americans-- she talks weird. I know I'm one to talk here. But she speaks in a particular kind of language. Here she is in a press conference talking about Muslims in America.
这位夏洛特·比尔斯女士曾是麦迪逊大道上的广告大亨，如今她大幅减薪，出任负责这项工作的副国务卿。虽然她目前宣布的一些措施极其合理——比如加强与外国记者的沟通，设立交流项目让更多穆斯林世界的人能接触并了解真正的美国人——但她说话的方式很古怪。我知道我没资格评论这点，但她确实使用着一种特别的语言。下面是她在新闻发布会上谈论美国穆斯林时的片段。
Their conversion rate is astonishing. 30% conversion in each year is about the fastest growing religion in this country and a good number for any sales team. Here's a sales curve any corporation would envy. These are the percent of mosques founded in the US over the last few years. It's obviously a growing, vital religion with some very wonderful people who have a pretty remarkable life here in the United States.
他们的转化率惊人。每年 30% 的转化率，大约是这个国家增长最快的宗教，对任何销售团队来说都是个不错的数字。这是一条任何企业都会羡慕的销售曲线。这些是过去几年在美国建立的清真寺比例。这显然是一个充满活力、不断增长的宗教，信众中有些非常棒的人，他们在我们美国过着相当不错的生活。
To consider all the difficulties the United States faces in this effort, to win the hearts and minds around the Muslim world, consider for a moment what it takes to do a regular advertising campaign, to do something as simple as sell laundry detergent in Muslim Afghanistan and Pakistan. Up until very recently, Zdenka Milanovich was based in Karachi for the global ad agency Saatchi and Saatchi, charged with selling Tide or the version of Tide that they use over there. It's called Ariel. And it is for handwashing since only 1% of the population has access to a washing machine. She said working in that part of the world was unlike any advertising she had ever done before.
要考虑到美国在这一努力中所面临的所有困难，要赢得穆斯林世界的人心，试想一下，开展一场普通的广告活动需要什么，比如在穆斯林国家阿富汗和巴基斯坦卖洗衣粉，哪怕是这么简单的事。直到最近，兹登卡·米拉诺维奇还在卡拉奇为全球广告代理公司盛世长城工作，负责销售“汰渍”或他们在当地使用的版本。它叫“Ariel”。由于只有 1% 的人口拥有洗衣机，它是专门用于手洗的。她说，在世界那个地区工作，与她做过的任何广告活动都截然不同。
For me, everything that I knew as the principals in advertising is something that I knew that I had to completely forget about.
对我来说，我所知的广告学原则，我必须全部忘掉。
Zdenka did this interview with our show and with the fine National Public Radio program On the Media.
兹登卡接受了我们节目和全国公共广播电台优秀的《媒体观察》节目的采访。
Because we're facing with a completely different type of consumers. The average salary in Pakistan, the real one is $5 per month. The literacy rate, the real one, for women is 4%, 5%. For men, it's higher, of course, 37%.
因为我们面对的是完全不同类型的消费者。巴基斯坦的平均工资，实际收入是每月 5 美元。女性的识字率，真实数据是 4% 到 5%。男性当然高一些，有 37%。
Then there was the fact that although it was women who washed clothes, it was men who made the purchasing decisions. Women didn't read magazines. They didn't see much TV. Zdenka had a product for them that she couldn't advertise to them. So the ad agency did a focus group and was sort of taken aback when six women, completely covered, in black, came in to talk about detergent and about the ads that the agency was thinking of running.
还有一个事实是，虽然洗衣服的是女性，但做购买决定的是男性。女性不看杂志，她们看电视也不多。兹登卡手里的产品是给她们用的，但她却没法向她们做广告。于是广告公司做了一个焦点小组访谈，当六位全身裹在黑袍里的女性进来谈论洗衣粉和公司构思的广告时，他们着实吃了一惊。
We exposed them to certain commercials. We just wanted to get some kind of insights. And after showing them the concepts, asking them to tell us what do they really think and which one would they chose, what they said is that they wouldn't use any. And they have to be asked, why. They said, because we just can't use it, we don't believe in this product because it's too expensive.
我们向她们展示了一些广告。我们只是想获得一些洞察。看完这些概念广告，问她们真正的想法，以及会选哪一个时，她们说她们一个都不会用。我们不得不问为什么。她们说，因为我们根本用不起，我们不相信这个产品，因为它太贵了。
They know, and they have perception that your brand is expensive because it has a foreign image. This is why it's not good. And I remember me, I just got home. And I was back in the office, and I didn't know what to do. Then I called certain people working in strategic planning in Dubai to understand what to do because they are not listening, and what is they way to approach them.
她们知道，而且她们有一种感知，觉得这个品牌昂贵是因为它带有外国形象。这就是它不好的原因。我记得我刚到家，回到办公室，我不知道该怎么办。于是我打电话给迪拜从事战略规划的人员，想了解该怎么做，因为她们不听，我们需要找到接近她们的方法。
So here's how they turned Ariel from a newcomer into the number one best-selling detergent in these Muslim countries. First, they decided that if the brand's foreignness was a problem, if foreignness made Ariel untrustworthy, then they needed to use, as their local spokesman, people that everyone would trust, which meant local people, real people. The ad agency gave them Ariel to use for a while and then filmed them talking about how great it is.
这就是他们如何将 Ariel 从一个新来者变成这些穆斯林国家销量第一的洗衣粉的方法。首先，他们认定如果品牌的“外国感”是个问题，如果外国感让 Ariel 变得不可信，那么他们就需要使用当地人——每个人都信任的真人——作为当地代言人。广告公司给他们 Ariel 洗衣粉试用一段时间，然后拍摄他们谈论产品有多好用。
We wanted to create the story about unfortunate people and how our product really contributed to better life. So we created real stories, for example, using a guy having four children and really with the hope to put his children in the good school, to offer them good education. Because the two main hopes for the people are to get the daughters married and to get sons educated.
我们想创造关于不幸者的故事，以及我们的产品如何真正为更好的生活做出贡献。因此，我们创造了真实的故事，例如，一个有四个孩子的男人，真心希望送孩子们去好的学校，给他们提供良好的教育。因为人们心中两个主要的希望就是让女儿出嫁，让儿子受教育。
And this is what we did. We just asked the guy to talk in front of a camera that he wants to educate his children, he is a poor man. He can't afford it to do it with one job. This is why he actually has to do two jobs. And because not having enough clothes, his wife helps him by washing with Ariel to look impeccable, working two jobs. And here is the hope for the future.
这就是我们做的。我们只是让那个人在镜头前说他想教育孩子，他是个穷人。他做一份工作供不起，这就是为什么他实际上必须做两份工作。因为衣服不够，他的妻子用 Ariel 洗涤，让他工作两份工作时看起来也能干干净净。这就是未来的希望。
And so what does the US need to do to win the hearts and minds of these same people? Well, Zdenka says that the US needs to let people know that it is on their side, same as Ariel did. And this is where it gets tricky. Because after all, in these countries, plenty of people are mad at the United States because they believe that we are emphatically not on their side. We do things that they disagree with. We support local governments they don't like. We drop bombs that sometimes hit civilians. We give money and arms to the state of Israel. And so there are people that we are not going to persuade.
那么美国需要做些什么来赢得这群人的心呢？兹登卡说，美国需要像 Ariel 那样，让人知道它站在他们这一边。而这正是棘手的地方。因为毕竟，在这些国家，很多人对美国感到愤怒，因为他们认为我们绝对没有站在他们这一边。我们做的事情他们不同意，我们支持他们不喜欢的当地政府，我们投下的炸弹有时会击中平民，我们给以色列国家提供资金和武器。所以，有些人我们是无法说服的。
Well, obviously, in marketing in general, a good advertisement cannot compensate for a faulty product.
嗯，显而易见，在一般的市场营销中，好的广告无法弥补有缺陷的产品。
John Quelch is a professor of marketing at the Harvard Business School and author of a book of case studies on how to market products in the Muslim world.
约翰·奎尔奇是哈佛商学院的市场营销学教授，也是一本关于如何在穆斯林世界营销产品案例研究的书的作者。
So there will undoubtedly be a certain core, a certain set of individuals in each of these Muslim countries whom advertising will not be able to achieve anything with because the policies will still not be perceived as being satisfactory. The problem here is more than a communications problem. It's a problem that relates to policy. It's a problem that relates to the degree to which, first of all, that they don't know the United States.
因此，在每个穆斯林国家，无疑都会有一小部分人，无论广告怎么做都无济于事，因为他们依然会认为美国的政策不令人满意。这里的问题不仅仅是沟通问题，而是政策问题。这与他们并不了解美国这一程度有着直接关联。
Here's what beginners we are at selling ourselves in most Muslim countries. John Quelch says, we don't even have the most basic polling data to tell us what people think of us. How many people hate us so much that they will never be persuaded? How many might be open to hearing our side of things?
这就是我们在大多数穆斯林国家推销自己方面的“新手”程度。约翰·奎尔奇说，我们甚至连最基本的民意数据都没有，不知道人们是怎么看我们的。到底有多少人恨我们恨到永远无法被说服？又有多少人可能愿意听听我们的立场？
This is, in my opinion, a generation-long effort.
在我看来，这是一场需要一代人努力的工作。
And as our nation embarks on this campaign for hearts and minds, we thought here at This American Life that it might be helpful to broadcast on the radio a cautionary tale or two, stories of people in wartime trying to win hearts and minds who, at some point, started to believe their own propaganda which, I guess, is kind of an occupational hazard. And they lost important battles because of that.
正当我国开始这场争取民心的运动时，我们《美国生活》认为，在广播里讲几个警世故事可能会有所帮助，讲述一些战时试图争取民心的人，在某个时刻开始相信自己的宣传——我想这是一种职业病——最终因此输掉了重要战役的故事。
Our program today in two acts. Act One, Don't Believe Anything You Hear On The Radio. In that act, we bring you what we believe are tapes that have never been broadcast in the United States, tapes of a clandestine radio station that the CIA set up back in the good old, bad old days of the 1950s to overthrow a central American government, which they succeeded in doing, using the immense power of radio. Or that's what the CIA believed anyway.
我们今天的节目分两幕。第一幕，“别相信你在广播里听到的任何话”。在这一幕中，我们为您带来我们认为从未在美国广播中播放过的录音带，那是中央情报局在 20 世纪 50 年代那个“美好又糟糕的旧时代”建立的一家秘密电台的录音，目的是推翻一个中美洲国家的政府，他们成功了，利用了广播的巨大威力。或者说，中情局是这么认为的。
Act Two, Live On Stage By The Sword, Die On Stage By The Sword. In that act, a story of wartime, of altruism and self-interest, of believing one's own publicity, and of a 50-year campaign for hearts and minds that was better known as The Bob Hope USO Tour. Stay with us.
第二幕，“舞台上的剑，舞台上的终结”。在那一幕中，我们将讲述一个关于战争、利他主义和私利的故事，关于相信自己的宣传，以及一场被称为“鲍勃·霍普劳军团巡演”的 50 年民心运动。请继续收听。
Act One, Don't Believe Anything You Hear On The Radio. Well, let's begin our show today with what was considered, sort of famously, actually, to be one of our nation's most successful campaigns to win hearts and minds. In retrospect, it serves as a kind of best case and worst case scenario for what we'd like to accomplish around the world these days. It involved a clandestine radio station that the CIA set up to help overthrow the government of Guatemala back in 1954.
第一幕，别相信你在广播里听到的任何话。我们今天的节目就从一个被认为——其实相当出名——是我国最成功的争取民心运动之一的项目开始吧。回首往事，它成了我们今天希望在世界各地实现的目标中，所谓最好和最坏情况的缩影。它涉及中情局 1954 年为推翻危地马拉政府而建立的一家秘密电台。
In the late 1990s, during a brief period when the CIA was declassifying old Cold War materials, tapes of this clandestine station were declassified thanks to the efforts of a nonprofit group called The National Security Archive. As best as we can tell, these tapes have never been broadcast in the United States. Nancy Updike tells this story.
20 世纪 90 年代末，中情局在短暂解密旧冷战材料的期间，在一个名为“国家安全档案馆”的非营利组织的努力下，该秘密电台的录音带被解密了。据我们所知，这些录音带从未在美国播放过。南希·厄普戴克讲述了这个故事。
The democratically elected president of Guatemala, Jacobo Arbenz, did a few things to get on the wrong side of the United States government. For one, he tangled with a very powerful American company called United Fruit. They grew and exported bananas. They were also Guatemala's largest private employer and its biggest landowner. Most of the 566,000 acres United Fruit owned in Guatemala were uncultivated.
危地马拉民主选举产生的总统哈科沃·阿本斯做了一些让美国政府不快的事。首先，他与一家强大的美国公司——联合果品公司——发生了冲突。他们种植并出口香蕉，也是危地马拉最大的私人雇主和最大的地主。联合果品公司在危地马拉拥有的 56.6 万英亩土地中，大部分都是未开垦的。
And when Arbenz came to power, he started nationalizing the country's land, buying up tens of thousands of those uncultivated acres for a nominal fee and giving them out to peasants. United Fruit complained to the US government. It was the height of the Cold War, Arbenz had communists among his advisers, and the US didn't want Guatemala to become a Soviet beachhead. Guatemala, after all, was only a four-hour flight from New Orleans, a representative from Ohio darkly reminded Congress.
当阿本斯上台后，他开始将国家土地国有化，以象征性的费用收购了成千上万英亩未开垦的土地，并分发给农民。联合果品公司向美国政府抱怨。当时正值冷战高峰，阿本斯的顾问中有共产党人，美国不希望危地马拉成为苏联的滩头阵地。一位来自俄亥俄州的议员阴沉地提醒国会，毕竟危地马拉距离新奥尔良只有四小时的飞行航程。
Because Eisenhower didn't want to seem like he was intervening in another country's affairs, he sent the CIA. They were given a couple of old airplanes that would fly over the capital to scare people, drop leaflets and, very rarely, a bomb. The CIA had a different president in mind for Guatemala, a disgruntled lieutenant colonel in exile named Castillo Armas. The CIA dubbed him, "The Liberator."
因为艾森豪威尔不想看起来像在干涉别国内政，他派出了中情局。他们得到几架旧飞机，飞越首都以吓唬人们、散发传单，极少情况下还会投下一枚炸弹。中情局为危地马拉物色了另一位总统人选——一位叫卡斯蒂略·阿马斯的流亡中校，心怀不满。中情局给他起了个绰号叫“解放者”。
The military that Castillo Armas had, which the CIA put together for him, was a ragtag force.
卡斯蒂略·阿马斯手下的军队，是由中情局为他拼凑起来的，是一支乌合之众。
This is Nick Grace. I'm going to tell you who he is in a minute.
这是尼克·格雷斯。待会儿我会告诉你们他是谁。
This was essentially an army that was toothless. And in order to promote the army, if you will, essentially, they depended upon propaganda.
这本质上是一支“没牙”的军队。为了推销这支军队，他们基本上依赖于宣传。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
This is the propaganda outfit the CIA set up, Radio Liberacion, Liberation Radio. And it was basically three Guatemalan guys that the CIA recruited, funded, and trained in psychological warfare-- disinformation, propaganda, scare tactics. From May through July of 1954, these guys went on the air to tell Guatemala about the bold, homegrown liberation movement they were part of, a movement to free the country from the iron grip of international Communism. This, of course, was a lie. There was no homegrown liberation movement, only a CIA plot.
这就是中情局建立的宣传机构——“解放电台”。它基本上由三个危地马拉人组成，由中情局招募、资助并进行心理战训练——包括虚假信息、宣传、恐吓手段。从 1954 年 5 月到 7 月，这些人通过广播向危地马拉民众讲述他们参与的一场大胆的本土解放运动，一场将国家从国际共产主义铁蹄下解放出来的运动。这当然是谎言。根本没有什么本土解放运动，只有中情局的阴谋。
It essentially was an elaborate puppet show that was played out over the airwaves.
它本质上是一场在无线电波上表演的精心策划的木偶戏。
Which brings us back to Nick Grace. He collects clandestine broadcasts from around the world and is probably the only person alive who's listened to all 54 of the tapes of Radio Liberacion.
这让我们回到了尼克·格雷斯身上。他收藏了来自世界各地的秘密广播，可能是世界上唯一听过所有 54 盘“解放电台”录音带的人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
This was an air check. The announcer states, "Every Guatemalan should have, as symbols in his struggle against Communism, God, fatherland, and liberty against Communism, against the vices of the past. For a true democracy, this is Radio Liberacion."
这是一次试音。播音员宣称：“每个危地马拉人，在反抗共产主义的斗争中，都应以神、祖国和自由作为旗帜。反对共产主义，反对过去的恶习。为了一个真正的民主国家，这里是解放电台。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
"Operating on its clandestine shortwave transmitter from some secret place in the Republic of Guatemala."
“在危地马拉共和国某处秘密地点，利用秘密短波发射机进行广播。”
Explain do you know how much was pre-recorded and how much they did live on the spot?
你能解释一下有多少是预录的，有多少是现场直播的吗？
That's tough to say. I think, on the whole, perhaps roughly 80% to 90% of it was pre-recorded in Florida, Opa-Locka, and brought down to the transmitter site-- which we believe was in Nicaragua-- by diplomatic pouch.
这很难说。我认为总体上大约 80% 到 90% 是在佛罗里达州奥帕洛卡预录的，然后通过外交信袋送到我们认为位于尼加拉瓜的发射台现场。
So these very passionate, patriotic exhortations to free Guatemala from some outside influence were all recorded in Florida?
所以这些充满激情、呼吁将危地马拉从外部势力影响下解放出来的演说，全是在佛罗里达录制的？
Yeah, pretty much. Up until mid-June.
是的，基本上是这样。直到 6 月中旬。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
This broadcast was, in fact, one of the ones that was made in the bush, so to speak.
这次广播事实上是在所谓的“丛林”中制作的录音之一。
So it was not recorded in Florida, you're saying?
所以你的意思是，这不是在佛罗里达录制的？
No, this was recorded in Nicaragua. Do you hear the hum on the audio?
不，这是在尼加拉瓜录制的。你听到音频里的嗡嗡声了吗？
Yeah, what is it?
听到了，那是什么？
They set up so quickly in Nicaragua that they weren't even able to ground their equipment properly. In all of the broadcasts that were done in the jungle, you can hear this hum.
他们在尼加拉瓜建立得太仓促，甚至没能给设备做好接地。在丛林里进行的所有广播中，你都能听到这种嗡嗡声。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
They announce, "Radio Liberacion calling Agent Bernardo. Wait at the agreed place. Two hours later, launch the attack in sector R-25. The map shows the exact location of the target. Good luck. Signed, The High Command." They were essentially sending the message to the government that we have maps, we've got agents, we have already chopped up Guatemala into various sectors, we've got a High Command, we're well armed, and we're right at your doorstep.
他们宣布：“解放电台呼叫贝尔纳多特工。在约定地点等候。两小时后在 R-25 区域发动袭击。地图显示目标的确切位置。祝你好运。签名：最高指挥部。”他们本质上是在向政府传达这样一个信息：我们有地图，我们有特工，我们已经把危地马拉划分成了各个区域，我们有最高指挥部，我们装备精良，而且我们就在你们家门口。
What was actually happening?
当时实际上发生了什么？
Absolutely nothing is happening. An interesting thing about this is that he says, "Tomorrow at 9,300 hours, you will receive the requested equipment."
什么都没发生。有趣的是，他说：“明天 9300 时，你将收到要求的装备。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
Well, 9,300 hours, there's no such term. So you can see--
嗯，9300 时，根本没有这种说法。所以你可以看出——
I heard that, and I thought, what is that? Is it some sort of different military clock? Or they didn't know what they were talking about?
我听到了，我心想，那是什么？是什么特殊的军事时钟吗？还是他们根本不知道自己在说什么？
They, essentially, didn't know what they were talking about.
他们本质上是不知道自己在说什么。
I wonder if there was any CIA guy listening who heard them say, "9,300 hours" and just went, oh, no, don't say that.
我想知道当时有没有中情局的人听到他们说“9300 时”然后惊呼：噢不，别那么说。
I think the CIA, at this point, was very happy with the results.
我想中情局当时对结果非常满意。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
All right. What are they doing here?
好吧，他们在这儿干什么？
Here, they're sending a quote unquote "coded message" to the guerrilla army, saying, "There's an important message. And here we go."
这里，他们正在向游击队发送所谓“加密信息”，说：“有重要信息。我们要开始了。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
"Our house--"
“我们的房子——”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
"--has seven doors--"
“——有七扇门——”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
"--all are green--"
“——全都是绿色的——”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
"--except one--"
“——除了其中一扇——”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
"--which is yellow."
“——是黄色的。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
The perception is that it's a coded message, that something is going to result out of this announcement. Because people had been hearing these kinds of announcements for a month and a half, as well as hearing announcements saying, look out your window, step outside on your patio, and step out into the streets in five minutes, a present will come to you. They step outside, and these anti-government leaflets are dropped out of these aircraft.
人们的感知是这是一条加密信息，会有什么事情发生。因为人们已经听了一个半月的这种广播，同时也听到过这样的广播：“看看窗外，走到你的院子里，五分钟后走到街上，会有礼物送给你。”他们走到外面，飞机就投下了这些反政府传单。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
Now this one is completely different from the other ones. He's almost being a real DJ in a way, where he's coming on and he's being very intimate and saying, "Hi. What's up? How are you? I'm glad."
现在这一段和之前的完全不同。他几乎像个真正的广播 DJ，语气非常亲切，说：“嗨，怎么了？你好吗？很高兴。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
"Don't worry about us." The rest of them are so bombastic, and this one is so--
“别担心我们。”其他的都很夸张，而这一段是如此——
Personable?
平易近人？
Yeah. Well, and so intimate. It's just like he's one guy, and he's talking directly to you.
是的，而且如此亲密。就像只有他一个人，直接在对你说话。
That's what, essentially, they were trying to do, personalize the people behind the microphone. They also wanted to put across the fact that they were supposedly broadcasting from the jungle, from the mountains and that it's very tranquil, the air is clean, there are lots of wild animals.
这本质上就是他们试图做的：将麦克风后的人格化。他们还想让人相信他们是在丛林、山区里广播，那里非常宁静，空气清新，有很多野生动物。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
For the populace, hearing that, they think, gosh, there's an area of my country which the government has no reach. "There may have been hardships," as he says. "But yet, the warm support that we get from people everywhere is strong," he says. "It's very satisfying."
民众听到后会想，天哪，我的国家竟然有一块政府触及不到的区域。“尽管有艰辛，”他说，“但我们从各地人民那里得到的支持是强大的，”他说，“这令人非常满意。”
Well, I was a young boy, I was 11 years old, when we started to listen to Radio Liberacion. That was the name that it took. The slogan was there from the very beginning, I believe. Dios, Patria, Libertad. God, Fatherland, Liberty.
好吧，我还是个 11 岁的小男孩时，就开始听“解放电台”了。那是它用的名字。我相信那个口号从一开始就在那里：神、祖国、自由。
Raul Molina is 58 years old and now lives in New York City. His father worked for United Fruit. They lived in Guatemala City. And every day, the whole family would listen to both the government station and Radio Liberacion. They wanted to stay well informed. Molina and I listened to some of the broadcasts. He hadn't heard them since he was a kid.
劳尔·莫利纳现年 58 岁，住在纽约市。他父亲曾为联合果品公司工作。他们住在危地马拉城。每天全家都会听政府的电台和解放电台。他们想保持信息灵通。我和莫利纳听了一些广播。他自从小时候后就没再听过这些了。
OK. So let's play one of these.
好的，那我们放一段这个。
That's the national anthem of Guatemala playing.
这是危地马拉的国歌在播放。
Molina is a serious man with a round face. He fled Guatemala in 1980, fearing for his life. He was a university president, and the army was routinely shooting people like him. Now he works as a translator for the UN. I watched his face for reactions to the tapes, but mostly he just listened, intently.
莫利纳是一个表情严肃、圆脸的人。他 1980 年因担心生命安全逃离了危地马拉。他曾是大学校长，军队经常枪杀像他这样的人。现在他在联合国担任翻译。我观察他的脸，看他对这些录音有什么反应，但大多时候他只是在认真倾听。
You just laughed a little bit. What were you laughing about?
你刚才笑了一下。你在笑什么？
Well, I was laughing about "from a secret place," like it was very much in the outskirts of Guatemala and so on. They made us believe that they were somewhere else.
嗯，我在笑“来自一个秘密地点”，好像它就在危地马拉郊外似的。他们让我们相信他们在其他地方。
And you did believe that they were in the jungles?
你们当时确实相信他们在丛林里吗？
Certainly, we did believe. We thought that they might be probably in one of the mountains close to the border to Honduras. Everyone was thinking that that was the case.
当然，我们确实相信。我们当时想他们可能在靠近洪都拉斯边境的山区里的某处。大家都是这么想的。
When did your family realize that these broadcasts weren't real?
你们家人什么时候意识到这些广播不是真的？
Well, most Guatemalans realized many years afterwards. We lived through a period from 1954 easily to the early '60s believing most of what had been played on this station.
嗯，大多数危地马拉人是很多年后才意识到的。从 1954 年到 60 年代初，我们一直生活在相信这个电台播放的大部分内容中。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
Do you remember these guys' voices? Are they familiar?
你还记得这些人的声音吗？熟悉吗？
Yes. And one of them is Lionel Sisniega Otero who is still a politician in Guatemala.
是的，其中一个是利昂内尔·西斯涅加·奥特罗，他现在仍然是危地马拉的政客。
He's still in Guatemala? He's still--
他还在危地马拉？他还在——
He's in Guatemala. And he's in politics. He's with the present government as a matter of fact.
他在危地马拉。而且还在从政。事实上，他在现在的政府里任职。
Wow. How do you feel about that?
哇。你对此有何感想？
Well, I feel very bad about the present government in Guatemala, to tell you the truth. We have a neo-fascist regime in Guatemala.
老实说，我对危地马拉现在的政府感觉很糟糕。我们现在正处于一个新法西斯政权统治下。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
Radio Liberacion was such elaborate deception, the CIA guy running the radio operation was a former actor and a writer. And he put the thing together like a play. There's one broadcast where they even staged a fake takeover of the station, as though government soldiers had suddenly discovered their plucky clandestine outfit in the mountains and had tried to run them off the air. The drama comes in the middle of a regular broadcast. The announcer is talking. And then all of a sudden, you start to hear a little commotion in the background.
“解放电台”是一个极其复杂的骗局。负责电台运作的中情局人员曾是一名演员和作家。他把这一切编排得像一场戏。有一次广播里，他们甚至伪造了电台被占领的场景，好像政府军突然发现了他们在山里的秘密电台，并试图切断他们的广播。戏剧性的情节发生在常规广播中间。播音员正在说话，突然，你开始听到背景里有一点骚动。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
[SOUND OF AN EXPLOSION]
[爆炸声]
[SPEAKING SPANISH FRANTICALLY]
[惊恐的西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
He seems distracted. Other people are talking behind him. Someone is saying, "Shh, shh." Then you notice the announcer sounds out of breath.
他看起来很心烦。背景里有其他人说话。有人说：“嘘，嘘。”然后你注意到播音员听起来上气不接下气。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Abruptly, there's an increase in the scuffling in the background, and it escalates to the denouement.
背景中的扭打声突然增加，升级到了高潮。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
[SOUND OF PEOPLE YELLING]
[人们的叫喊声]
[SOUND OF GUNSHOTS]
[枪声]
[SOUND OF A WOMAN SCREAMING]
[女人的尖叫声]
And then silence. The station goes off the air at this point, leaving listeners to wonder what had happened.
然后是寂静。电台此时中断了广播，留下听众去猜测发生了什么。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Two days later, Radio Liberacion came back on the air and smugly explained that although government thugs had tried to shut down their transmitter, the brave rebels had thwarted them.
两天后，“解放电台”又恢复了广播，自鸣得意地解释说，尽管政府暴徒试图关闭他们的发射机，但英勇的叛军挫败了他们。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
After two months of broadcasts, the government of Guatemala fell. And it was a success that cemented the reputation of the fledgling Central Intelligence Agency. It's hard to remember this today, but in 1954, the CIA was still a relatively young organization, only seven years old, still in the midst of trying to define and justify itself. When Arbenz fell, the CIA was ecstatic. Its critics turned into fans. Eisenhower, in his memoirs, called the overthrow of Arbenz one of his proudest moments. The operation went down in CIA history as quote, "an unblemished triumph."
两个月广播后，危地马拉政府倒台了。这次成功巩固了羽翼未丰的中央情报局的名声。今天很难回想起这一点，但在 1954 年，中情局还是一个相对年轻的组织，只有 7 岁，还在试图定义和证明自己的存在。当阿本斯倒台时，中情局欣喜若狂。它的批评者变成了粉丝。艾森豪威尔在回忆录中将推翻阿本斯称为他最引以为傲的时刻之一。这次行动在中情局历史上被记录为“完美的胜利”。
Nick Cullather is a historian the CIA hired a few years ago to write an official internal history of what happened. Cullather was given full access to all documents related to the Guatemalan coup. He says that in spite of everything else that went into the operation-- the CIA had tried to infiltrate the army and foment student uprisings, the planes had increased their flights over the capital-- there was no doubt in the CIA's mind what had made the critical difference.
尼克·卡拉瑟是一位中情局几年前聘请的历史学家，旨在撰写一份关于当时发生之事的官方内部历史。卡拉瑟被允许完全查阅所有与危地马拉政变相关的文档。他说，尽管行动中包含了其他一切因素——中情局试图渗透军队、煽动学生起义、飞机增加了在首都上空的飞行次数——但毫无疑问，中情局认为起到决定性作用的是广播。
It seemed, to the CIA, that the radio had caused the government and President Arbenz to inexplicably crack psychologically. President Arbenz left the presidential palace, walked across the street to the embassy of Mexico, and abdicated. And that was the conclusion of the operation. And at that point, everything else was failing. The secret army that they had assembled was in full retreat. The air operations appeared not to be having any result. The student groups that they'd organized to foment rebellion in the capital city had all been rounded up, jailed, and executed. Nothing else was going except the radio operation. So it seemed to them that the radio operation must have worked.
在中情局看来，是广播导致了政府和阿本斯总统在心理上莫名其妙地崩溃了。阿本斯总统离开了总统府，穿过街道走到墨西哥大使馆，并宣布退位。行动至此结束。当时其他的一切都在失败。他们组建的秘密军队在全面溃退，空中行动似乎没有任何结果，他们在首都组织起来煽动叛乱的学生团体全部被抓获、监禁并处决。除了广播运作之外，什么进展都没有。所以他们认为，广播运作一定起作用了。
But the CIA never did a serious analysis of what had happened in Guatemala and why it happened. They didn't talk to any Guatemalans. They didn't even go back over their own operation to determine what had worked. They relied on after-action reports provided by the agents involved. The propaganda guys were the best storytellers, and their version of events stuck. In other words, the agency hired a bunch of liars, taught them to lie better, and then believed them.
但中情局从未对危地马拉发生的事件及其原因进行过认真的分析。他们没有与任何危地马拉人交谈。他们甚至没有回顾自己的行动来确定什么是有效的。他们依赖于相关特工提供的“行动后报告”。宣传人员是最会讲故事的人，他们对事件的描述就这么留了下来。换句话说，中情局雇了一群骗子，教他们更好地撒谎，然后相信了他们。
It created a legend about the types of operations that could be successful, the belief that, at very low cost and with very little loss of life, one could overthrow a government if one used the right combination of military and psychological action. But it really also set up the whole repertoire that the CIA continues to use today. If you take a look at the operations in Central America in the 1980s, the operations following the Gulf War in Iraq, some of the operations that are underway in Afghanistan today, it's the same set of ideas. Small actions that create a climate of opinion within the country that leads to a feeling of inevitable doom.
这创造了一个关于何种行动可以取得成功的传奇：即相信以极低的成本和极小的人员伤亡，如果使用军事和心理行动的正确组合，就能推翻一个政府。但它也确实奠定了中情局今天继续使用的整套剧本。如果你看看 20 世纪 80 年代在中美洲的行动、伊拉克海湾战争后的行动、今天在阿富汗正在进行的一些行动，都是同样的一套理念。小的行动在国家内部制造一种舆论氛围，导致一种不可避免的厄运感。
But this whole legend is built on a story that's not true. Arbenz didn't resign because the radio broadcasts psyched him out. He resigned because he could see that the United States would not stop until he was gone. Four months before the coup, the US pushed a resolution through the Organization of American States essentially giving it the right to intervene in Guatemala at will. When Arbenz managed to get actual documentation of the CIA plot against him and made the information public, the State Department denounced it as a desperate and transparent communist propaganda effort, probably masterminded in Moscow. And the US press, from liberal to conservative, bought this.
但整个传奇建立在一个不真实的故事之上。阿本斯不是因为广播宣传让他崩溃而辞职的。他辞职是因为他明白，美国不达目的誓不罢休。政变前四个月，美国在美洲国家组织通过了一项决议，实质上赋予其在危地马拉随意干预的权利。当阿本斯设法获得美国针对他的中情局阴谋的实际文件并向公众发布时，美国国务院将其斥为绝望且透明的共产主义宣传努力，可能是在莫斯科策划的。而从自由派到保守派的美国媒体，都相信了这一点。
In his final days, Arbenz appealed to the United Nations Security Council. The US strong-armed the Council, and it voted not to hear the case. But even after all this, he still might have hung on. In the end, Arbenz only resigned when his frightened army sent word from the field that if he didn't step down, they would march to the capital and depose him themselves. They, too, believed it was only a matter of time before the US would invade.
在最后的日子里，阿本斯向联合国安理会提出申诉。美国向安理会施压，最终投票拒绝听取该案件。但即便如此，他本可能坚持下去。最终，阿本斯只有在受惊的军队从前线传来消息说如果他不下台，他们就会开进首都亲手推翻他时才辞职。他们也认为美国入侵只是时间问题。
It seemed the only people who didn't see it that way were in the CIA. Here's historian Nick Cullather.
似乎只有中情局的人不这么看。这是历史学家尼克·卡拉瑟。
It's very hard for me to separate the notion of force from the notion of propaganda because propaganda is always backed by force. When the Germans were attacking the French along the Maginot Line, they first put sirens on the Stuka dive bombers because the bombs themselves weren't having a great deal of effect on the French troops. But the sirens really made them run. So was that force or was that propaganda?
我很难将武力的概念与宣传的概念分离开来，因为宣传总是以武力为后盾。当德国人在马奇诺防线攻击法国人时，他们首先在斯图卡俯冲轰炸机上安装了警笛，因为炸弹本身对法军并没有产生太大影响。但警笛确实让他们四散奔逃。那么那是武力还是宣传？
I think the people in the CIA saw that as propaganda. But I think a lot of people would take a look at that and say, no, that's just another variety of military force.
我认为中情局的人将其视为宣传。但我认为很多人会审视这一点并说：不，那只是军事武力的另一种形式。
Cullather says, there are plenty of situations where it's right for us to use both force and propaganda, for us to intervene in the affairs of another country. Rwanda, for example, or the current war in Afghanistan. The problem, he says, is that we're not so good at facing the magnitude of that task. It's easier to destroy a government than to create one that's stable over the long term. In the CIA documents he examined, he found that the Agency's ideas about a future Guatemalan government were sketchy at best, sketchier, even, than our ideas about what kind of government should come to run Afghanistan.
卡拉瑟说，在很多情况下，我们使用武力和宣传、介入他国事务是正确的。例如卢旺达，或当前的阿富汗战争。但他认为问题在于，我们不太善于面对这项任务的艰巨性。摧毁一个政府比建立一个长期稳定的政府要容易得多。在他研究的中情局文档中，他发现该机构对于未来危地马拉政府的想法充其量是粗略的，甚至比我们对应该由什么样的政府来管理阿富汗的想法还要粗略。
In Guatemala, things didn't work out so well. The man the CIA deposed turned out to be the last truly democratic leader Guatemala had. Armas, the man the CIA picked to replace Arbenz, was assassinated three years into his repressive regime. And since then, it's been one long series of brutal military dictatorships interspersed with short-lived attempts at civilian rule. Again, here's Raul Molina who heard Radio Liberacion as a child.
在危地马拉，事情进展得并不顺利。被中情局废黜的人竟然是危地马拉最后一位真正民主的领导人。中情局选中取代阿本斯的阿马斯，在他高压统治的第三年就被暗杀了。从那以后，一系列残酷的军事独裁统治和短暂的平民统治尝试交替出现。再次引用那位小时候听过“解放电台”的劳尔·莫利纳的话。
I remember watching a movie. I think it is Eisenhower coming out of a plane and saying now that Guatemala had been liberated, Guatemala was going to be an example for the world. And it became an example to the world, but of the things that you should never do in a country. After that invasion, not a single day passed in Guatemala without violations of human rights with 200,000 Guatemalans killed and more than 45,000 Guatemalans disappeared. So that's certainly the cost of this adventure that we have just heard started [? that way. ?]
我记得看电影时，好像是艾森豪威尔从飞机上走下来，说现在危地马拉已经解放了，危地马拉将成为世界的榜样。它确实成了世界的榜样，但那是作为一个国家绝不应该做的榜样。那次入侵之后，危地马拉没有一天不在发生侵犯人权的行为，20 万危地马拉人丧生，超过 4.5 万危地马拉人失踪。所以这肯定是我们刚才听到的这次冒险所付出的代价。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
In this broadcast, Radio Liberacion is announcing the resignation of Arbenz. It's a triumphant speech about how his overthrow is a victory for those fighting against foreign control. But of course, the announcer is working for a foreign government. He says joyfully, "Radio Liberacion is now transmitting live from the liberated territory of Guatemala." Every single part of that sentence is untrue. The transmission is not live. He's not in Guatemala. And the country has not been liberated.
在这次广播中，“解放电台”宣布阿本斯辞职。这是一个关于他的下台对于反抗外国控制的人来说是一次胜利的凯旋演说。但当然，播音员是为外国政府工作的。他兴高采烈地说：“解放电台现在正在危地马拉的解放领土上直播。”那句话的每一个字都是谎言。广播不是直播，他不在危地马拉，国家也没有被解放。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Nancy Updike.
南希·厄普戴克。
[MUSIC - "COMMIE DRIVES A NOVA" BY IKE REILLY]
[音乐 - 艾克·赖利演唱的《Commie Drives a Nova》]
Coming up, Bob Hope's dog bites our reporter in a minute from Public Radio International and Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，鲍勃·霍普的狗咬了我们的记者。稍后请继续收听来自国际公共广播电台和芝加哥公共广播电台的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Hearts and Minds, a story of wartime and propaganda efforts and what happens when you start to believe your own propaganda. We've come to the second act of our show. Act Two, Live On Stage By The Sword, Die On Stage By The Sword.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种不同的故事。今天的节目主题是“民心”，关于战时和宣传努力，以及当你开始相信自己的宣传时会发生什么。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“舞台上的剑，舞台上的终结”。
So the cast of the movie Ocean's Eleven, George Clooney, Julia Roberts, Brad Pitt, Matt Damon, and the rest are going to entertain the troops at a US base in Turkey. This is not entirely altruistic. They will be there to coincide with the multimillion dollar publicity campaign for the film's opening December 7, a day that will, of course, live in infamy. By going to Turkey, they will get some free publicity back home, a nice video of the stars palling around with cheering troops. DVDs of the film will be sent to 11 grateful warships in the region. All of which brings to mind this story which our contributing editor Margy Rochlin tells.
所以《十一罗汉》的剧组人员——乔治·克鲁尼、茱莉亚·罗伯茨、布拉德·皮特、马特·达蒙以及其他人，要去土耳其的一个美军基地慰问部队。这并非完全出于利他主义。他们的行程将与该片 12 月 7 日上映前的数百万美元宣传活动重合——当然，这一天是“耻辱之日”。通过去土耳其，他们能在家乡获得一些免费的宣传，比如明星们与欢呼部队互动的一段漂亮视频。电影的 DVD 将会被送往该地区的 11 艘满怀感激的军舰上。所有这些都让人联想到了我们特约编辑玛吉·罗克林讲述的这个故事。
At the beginning of the Persian Gulf war, during the period when US forces were moving in, but no fighting had started, lots of soldiers found themselves stationed for months in the middle of nowhere, actually living and sleeping in battle formation, isolated from the outside world. So General Norman Schwarzkopf contacted Steve Martin, the actor and comedian, and asked him if he would go to the Middle East. That's how Martin and his then wife, the British actress Victoria Tennant, ended up on their very own mini USO tour.
波斯湾战争开始时，在美军进驻但尚未爆发战斗的期间，许多士兵发现自己驻扎在荒无人烟的地方长达数月，实际上是在战斗编队中生活和睡觉，与外界隔绝。因此，诺曼·施瓦茨科普夫将军联系了演员兼喜剧演员史蒂夫·马丁，问他是否愿意去中东。这就是马丁和当时他的妻子、英国女演员维多利亚·田纳特最终参加他们自己的小型劳军联合组织（USO）巡演的原因。
They flew to a Saudi air base near the Kuwaiti front line. And for about a week, they'd awaken at dawn, get into a troop carrier helicopter along with two pilots, two machine gunners, and a special Marine escort, and they'd visit soldiers stationed along the Iraqi-Kuwait border. Every 20 minutes or so, they'd land. And Steve Martin would climb on top of a tank, and about 75 soldiers would gather around. And for about a quarter of an hour, the comedian would just wing it. He'd clown around, answer questions, sign autographs, pose for pictures, whatever.
他们飞往科威特前线附近的沙特空军基地。大约一周的时间里，他们会在黎明醒来，与两名飞行员、两名机枪手和一名特别海军陆战队护卫一起挤进运兵直升机，探访驻扎在伊拉克-科威特边境沿线的士兵。每隔 20 分钟左右，他们就会着陆。史蒂夫·马丁会爬上一辆坦克，大约 75 名士兵会聚集在周围。大约一刻钟的时间里，这位喜剧演员会即兴发挥。他会扮丑、回答问题、签名、拍照，随你便。
Not wanting to be just the tag-along wife, Victoria Tennant came up with a plan. She'd move through the crowd, collecting names and telephone numbers from the soldiers along with messages that she could relay to their loved ones when she got home. It was such a simple idea, but coming from this rich, prim-looking British woman, it must have seemed unexpected and, therefore, doubly moving. They opened up to her. Single fathers asked her to call their children and say, "Your daddy loves you." Newly married men wanted her to let their brides know how much they were missed.
不想仅仅做一个跟班妻子，维多利亚·田纳特想出了一个计划。她在人群中穿梭，收集士兵们的名字和电话号码，以及她回家后可以转达给他们亲人的信息。这是一个如此简单的主意，但出自这位富有、看起来严谨的英国女士之口，一定显得出人意料，因此倍感触动。他们对她敞开了心扉。单身父亲请她给孩子打电话说：“爸爸爱你。”新婚男人想让她让新娘知道他们有多想念对方。
It took Victoria Tennant days to make all the calls. And the best thing about this story is you probably never heard it. And the reason why is because Steve Martin and Victoria Tennant didn't want it publicized. It was a pure, unselfish act, which brings us to Bob Hope.
维多利亚·田纳特花了几天时间拨打所有的电话。这个故事最好的一点是，你可能从未听说过它。原因在于史蒂夫·马丁和维多利亚·田纳特不想让它被宣传。这是一个纯粹、无私的行动，这把我们带向了鲍勃·霍普。
Bob Hope, of course, performed USO shows for a half century all over the world. It was a hearts and minds campaign with two fronts. The servicemen got a taste of home, and the people back home were reminded what great guys Bob Hope and all the other performers were. Now we at This American Life have no doubt at all that Bob Hope, and for that matter George Clooney and Brad Pitt, are all great, great guys. But we were curious about the intersection of public service and self-interest that occurs at a USO show. Years ago, when Hope was still visiting the troops, Margy Rochlin talked with him about what he got out of it for a newspaper profile she was writing. And we asked her to pull out her old tapes of Bob Hope and explain it to us.
鲍勃·霍普当然在世界各地表演了半个世纪的 USO 演出。这是一场双管齐下的民心运动：军人品尝到了家乡的味道，而家乡的人们被提醒了鲍勃·霍普和其他表演者是多么伟大的人。现在，我们《美国生活》毫不怀疑鲍勃·霍普，甚至乔治·克鲁尼和布拉德·皮特都是伟大的人。但我们对 USO 演出中公共服务与私利之间的交集感到好奇。几年前，当霍普还在探访部队时，玛吉·罗克林曾为她正在写的报纸专题采访过他，了解他从中得到了什么。我们请她拿出鲍勃·霍普的旧录音带并向我们解释。
As best as I can figure, it started innocently enough for Bob Hope. By 1941, Bob Hope's three-year-old radio show had made him the top radio star in the country. Just before the war broke out, a representative from Pepsodent, the toothpaste company who sponsored the show, suggested to a reluctant Hope that he entertain the GIs at the March Field Air Base in Riverside, California. Hope said, no, he didn't think it was a good idea. Nobody listened to him.
据我所知，这对鲍勃·霍普来说开始得相当无辜。到 1941 年，鲍勃·霍普为期三年的广播节目已经让他成为全国顶级的广播明星。就在战争爆发前，赞助该节目的牙膏公司百事达的一位代表，向勉强的霍普建议去加州里弗赛德的马奇空军基地娱乐大兵。霍普说不，他认为这不是个好主意。没人听他的。
Next Tuesday, I was crawling on a bus going to March Field with Francis Langford, Jerry Colonna, Skinny Ennis, and the band. And the audience was sensational. So much so that I said, wait a minute, this is tremendous. And we started doing it every week.
接下来的周二，我正挤在前往马奇基地的巴士上，和弗朗西斯·朗福德、杰里·科隆纳、斯金尼·恩尼斯和乐队在一起。观众反响热烈。以至于我说，等一下，这太棒了。我们开始每周都做。
Went to Camp Pendleton, San Diego, Camp Cook, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] so and so. Everywhere around there, and finally, December, they declared war. Now it's dramatic. We went for five years, we played bases. And it was the most sensational thing, most emotional part of my life.
去了圣地亚哥的彭德尔顿营、库克营等等。在各个地方，终于在 12 月，他们宣战了。现在它变得戏剧性了。我们去了五年，我们在各个基地演出。这是我一生中最轰动、最感性的部分。
That's what he was in it for at first. Hope had never had an audience respond to him the way that the GIs did. In his 1990 memoir, Don't Shoot, It's Only Me, Hope explains that before he began the USO tours, his producer's equation for a radio show allowed for 23 minutes of jokes and music, 3 minutes for commercials, and roughly 3 minutes for laughter. But Hope's bits went over so huge at the army camps that they had to refigure the laugh time to 6 minutes.
这就是他起初的目的。霍普从未有过大兵们对他那种热烈的反响。在他 1990 年的回忆录《别开枪，那只是我》中，霍普解释说，在他开始 USO 巡演之前，制作人的节目公式允许 23 分钟的笑话和音乐、3 分钟广告，大约 3 分钟笑声。但霍普的片段在军营里反响太热烈，他们不得不重新计算笑声时间到 6 分钟。
Over the next 50 years, Hope took his show all over the world, performing on the flight decks of aircraft carriers and out in the jungle on hastily constructed stages. He was there during every war and major military action from World War II--
在接下来的 50 年里，霍普带着他的演出走向世界，在航空母舰的飞行甲板上和丛林中临时搭建的舞台上表演。他出现在从二战开始的每一次战争和重大军事行动中——
We have a nice show here with Francis Langford, Jerry Colonna, Tony Romano, Patty Thomas, and Barney Dean. I know you'll enjoy the girls. You remember, girls?
我们在这里和弗朗西斯·朗福德、杰里·科隆纳、托尼·罗马诺、帕蒂·托马斯和巴尼·迪恩一起演出。我知道你们会喜欢这些女孩的。你们还记得吗，女孩们？
--to the Berlin airlift and the Korean War--
——到柏林空运和朝鲜战争——
Ladies and gentlemen, this is the Second Infantry Division occupying Korea except on Saturday night. It's on Saturday night when they occupy Seoul.
女士们、先生们，这是占领朝鲜的第二步兵师，除了周六晚上。周六晚上他们占领首尔。
--to Vietnam--
——到越南——
No, but I'm very happy to be here at Tan Son Nhut, southeast Asia's biggest rocket base. Yes, mostly incoming.
不，但我很高兴来到东南亚最大的火箭基地——新山一。是的，主要是“ incoming”（指敌方炮火）。
--to Beirut and the Middle East in the '80s--
——到黎巴嫩和 80 年代的中东——
And may I tell you it's been a while since I've entertained servicemen. But Washington told me, if we can bring ships out of mothballs, why not you?
我可以告诉你们，我已经有一阵子没娱乐过军人了。但华盛顿告诉我，如果我们能把船从封存中拉出来，为什么不能把你拉出来呢？
--and the Persian Gulf in the '90s.
——以及 90 年代的波斯湾。
That program cost $70 billion, and I got a great idea. If those planes are invisible, let's not build any, but tell the Iraqis they're up there.
那个计划花了 700 亿美元，我有个好主意。如果那些飞机是隐形的，那我们干脆不造了，直接告诉伊拉克人它们就在上面。
Hope was the wisecracking master of ceremonies. From show to show, the only thing that changed was the guest stars involved. Big stars, Clark Gable, Fred Astaire, Mickey Mantle, Ann-Margret. There would definitely be a band, always beautiful women. Sometimes the women would sing, maybe Hope would bounce a few one-liners off of them. Mostly, their job was to run on stage wearing not very much. When they came out, the lonely GIs would howl their approval.
霍普是插科打诨的司仪。从一场演出到下一场，唯一改变的就是客串明星。大明星，克拉克·盖博、弗雷德·阿斯泰尔、米奇·曼特尔、安-玛格丽特。肯定会有乐队，永远有漂亮的女性。有时女性会唱歌，霍普可能会和她们讲几个俏皮话。她们的工作大多是在舞台上跑来跑去，穿着很少。当她们出来时，孤独的大兵们会发出认可的嚎叫。
I just want you boys to see what you're fighting for, that's all.
我只是想让你们这些男孩看看你们在为什么而战，就这样。
Several times his life was in danger. In Saigon, his hotel was bombed. During the Korean War, he was inadvertently landed on Wangsan Beach before the First Marine Division had taken it. One thing he was proud of. At each base, he'd tailor his material with inside jokes for the local servicemen.
他的生命有好几次处于危险之中。在西贡，他的酒店被炸。在朝鲜战争期间，他在第一海军陆战师占领旺山海滩之前被误导降落在那里。有一件事他很自豪：在每个基地，他都会为当地军人量身定做内幕笑话。
The Defense Department got a letter from up here signed by 300 GIs, 2 Seals and a misplaced gooney bird. And Colonel Jolly.
国防部从这里收到了一封信，由 300 名大兵、2 名海豹突击队员和一只走丢的信天翁签署。还有乔利上校。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Thank you very much. Here we are in U-Tapao, the gateway to beautiful downtown Sattahip.
非常感谢。我们在乌塔堡，通往美丽的萨塔希普市中心的门户。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Look at those guys hanging out the window. Room service must be late with the poo-ying.
看那些挂在窗边的家伙。客房服务一定是迟到了。
I don't even want to know what that joke means. To understand what the USO shows did for Bob Hope's career, you have to remember that he was already the most popular star on radio and in the movies when he began doing the tours. One of his biographers, Bill Faith, said the USO gave Bob Hope a popularity the likes of which we cannot even imagine today. It gave him the sheen of a national hero.
我甚至不想知道那个笑话是什么意思。要理解 USO 演出对鲍勃·霍普职业生涯的作用，你必须记住，当他开始巡演时，他已经是广播和电影中最受欢迎的明星了。他的传记作家之一比尔·费思说，USO 给鲍勃·霍普带来了一种我们今天无法想象的知名度。它赋予了他国家英雄的光芒。
And for a long time for Bob Hope, doing the USO tour was a balance of cheerful patriotism and good business. Until 1954, when the balance shifted and the business side of things took on a little more importance. 1954 was when Bob Hope began the tradition of taping the USO shows, then selling them as television specials to NBC. Arguably, they were the cornerstone on which he built the last 40 years of his career.
对于鲍勃·霍普来说，很长一段时间里，进行 USO 巡演是欢快的爱国主义与良好商业的平衡。直到 1954 年，平衡发生了偏移，商业因素变得更加重要。1954 年是鲍勃·霍普开始录制 USO 演出，然后作为电视特别节目卖给 NBC 的开始。可以说，这是他构筑职业生涯最后 40 年的基石。
A common misconception about the USO shows is that they raised money for the organization, which isn't true. In fact, there's always been controversy about who paid for what. Bob Hope says he paid all production costs and even lost money in the long run. But it's not clear how. The actors basically donated their time, although the USO says it occasionally paid them a small per diem. And everyone agrees that the Pentagon paid for transportation, most lodging, for the bulk of the bills.
关于 USO 演出一个常见的误解是，它们为该组织筹集了资金，这并非事实。事实上，一直以来都有关于谁付钱的争议。鲍勃·霍普说他支付了所有制作成本，长期来看甚至赔钱了。但尚不清楚怎么赔的。演员基本上捐出了他们的时间，尽管 USO 说偶尔会给他们很少的津贴。每个人都同意五角大楼支付了交通费、大部分住宿费，承担了大部分账单。
Now remember, Hope sold these shows to NBC. But let's say he did lose money. You could not put a price tag on what he got in return. He'd do the USO show every Christmas which would build an audience for other comedy specials throughout the year.
现在记住，霍普把这些节目卖给了 NBC。但即使他赔了钱，你也不可能给他换回的东西贴上价格标签。他会在每年圣诞节做 USO 演出，这为他全年的其他喜剧特别节目积累了观众。
Bob Hope presents the hilarious, unrehearsed antics of the stars, starring Lucille Ball, Milton Berle--
鲍勃·霍普呈现明星们滑稽、未经排练的闹剧，主演露西尔·鲍尔、米尔顿·伯尔——
Just like the USO shows, each special was almost identical. First came the eight minute opening monologue. He'd tell 35 to 40 jokes. Then came the guest stars, a song, and a corny skit segment at the end of the show.
就像 USO 演出一样，每个特别节目几乎是一模一样的。首先是八分钟的开场独白。他会讲 35 到 40 个笑话。然后是客串明星、一首歌，以及节目最后俗气的短剧环节。
In 1986, I went to observe the legendary comedian tape one of these specials for NBC. At one point, they did a spoof of Mutiny on the Bounty on a big wooden ship. Hope was Captain Bligh, John Denver was Fletcher Christian, Broadway musical star Howard Keel was the Bounty's alcoholic doctor. Morgan Brittany, who played Pam Ewing's evil half-sister on Dallas, was a prissy British missionary. I can't remember what Jonathan Winters played, but he was in drag. He was dressed as a Polynesian dancer girl, I think, in a grass skirt and coconut bra.
1986 年，我去观察这位传奇喜剧演员为 NBC 录制其中一个特别节目。有一次，他们在一艘大木船上恶搞了《叛舰喋血记》。霍普演布莱船长，约翰·丹佛演弗莱彻·克里斯蒂安，百老汇音乐剧明星霍华德·基尔演邦蒂号上酗酒的医生。在《达拉斯》中饰演帕姆·尤因邪恶继妹的摩根·布列塔尼演一个做作的英国传教士。我不记得乔纳森·温特斯演什么了，但他穿了女装。我想他打扮成一个波利尼西亚舞女，穿着草裙和椰子文胸。
It looked like the easiest job in the world. No one even pretended to have memorized their lines. They just woodenly read their dialogue from cue cards. If they flubbed a joke, the cameras just kept rolling. That was how they achieved the famous style of Bob Hope specials, or non-style really. It was supposed to be like watching famous people getting together for an hour to have a good time in front of the camera.
这看起来是世界上最容易的工作。没人假装背过台词。他们只是木然地读着提示卡上的对话。如果他们弄砸了一个笑话，摄像机就继续拍。这就是他们实现著名的鲍勃·霍普特别风格的方式，或者说其实是“非风格”。这本应看起来像是看名人在摄像机前聚在一起过上一段快乐时光。
In the TV business, these specials were famous because they always got top ratings, and they didn't cost Hope much to produce. Back in the '60s, Bob Hope had this amazing clause inserted into his contract. Charges by NBC technicians were frozen at 1961 rates. Back when NBC struck that deal with him, it might have seemed like a good way to keep Hope at the network. But 25 years had passed. If he wanted to have a set built, the fee was circa 1961. He paid next to nothing to use the editing and post-production facilities, their manpower, everything.
在电视行业，这些特别节目之所以出名，是因为它们总是获得顶级收视率，而且霍普的制作成本并不高。早在 60 年代，鲍勃·霍普就在合同中加入了一条神奇的条款：NBC 技术人员的费用冻结在 1961 年的水平。当 NBC 与他达成这笔交易时，这似乎是一种让霍普留在该网络的良策。但 25 年过去了。如果他想搭建一个场景，费用是 1961 年的水平。他几乎不用花什么钱来使用编辑和后期制作设施、人力资源等一切。
That was the whole beauty of his setup. He knew that people tuned in to a Bob Hope special to see Bob Hope. The costumes and talent were just window dressing. Why pay people to rehearse? Why waste money? Call it the most economical star-delivery system television has ever seen. This guy was a genius.
这就是他这一模式的绝妙之处。他知道人们收看鲍勃·霍普的特别节目是为了看鲍勃·霍普。服装和才艺只是装饰。为什么要付钱让人排练？为什么要浪费钱？称之为电视史上最高效的明星输出系统。这家伙是个天才。
Not long after I watched them film that sketch, I went to interview Bob Hope at his 50 room house on a quiet tree-lined street in the San Fernando Valley. Hope had two dogs, a black lab and a white Alsatian, and they followed us up the driveway, growling.
在我看完他们拍摄那个小品后不久，我去圣费尔南多谷一条安静、树木繁茂的街道上的鲍勃·霍普拥有 50 个房间的房子里采访他。霍普有两条狗，一只黑色拉布拉多和一只白色阿尔萨斯犬，它们跟着我们走上车道，低吼着。
Are you watching the dog?
你在看狗吗？
Hello, baby. Hello, baby. Don't look at her. Don't look at her. That's OK.
你好，宝贝。你好，宝贝。别看她。别看她。没关系。
When one of them nipped at me, Hope kept insisting they were completely harmless.
当其中一只咬我时，霍普坚持认为它们完全无害。
He's a good boy.
它是只好狗。
Ow. He just sort of grabbed my arm here.
噢。它刚才抓了我的手臂。
He's never bitten anybody but one of my writers. All right. All right.
它除了咬过我的一位作家，没咬过任何人。好吧。好吧。
Ouch. She just bit me again.
哎哟。她刚才又咬了我。
OK. Come on, hey. All right now. Don't start.
好的。来吧，嘿。好了。别开始了。
Things went downhill from there. Bob Hope and I had no chemistry, none. He'd tell jokes that I didn't get. And not only that, after he'd delivered the punch line, he'd lean towards me, fix me with his brown eyes, and gauge my response. So I'd laugh. The things I said only made him fall into long exasperated silences. It was awkward.
事情从那儿开始变糟糕了。我和鲍勃·霍普没有任何化学反应，一点也没有。他讲的笑话我听不懂。不仅如此，在他讲完笑话后，他会向我倾身，用棕色的眼睛盯着我，评估我的反应。所以我笑了。我说的话只会让他陷入漫长、恼怒的沉默。这太尴尬了。
So we ate lunch, creamed chicken and peas with rice. I think I wanted him to show me how he'd changed with the times, how he'd subtly tweaked his material to better reflect his age or adapted it so that it resonated with the popular culture. So I asked him a question.
所以我们吃了午餐，奶油鸡和豌豆配米饭。我想我希望他展示他如何随着时代改变，如何巧妙地调整他的材料以更好地反映他的年龄，或者调整它以引起流行文化的共鸣。所以我问了他一个问题。
Are you pretty sympathetic to the women's movement?
你对妇女运动很有同情心吗？
There I was sitting with a man in his early 80s who was still telling hubba-hubba jokes, and I'm quizzing him about the women's movement. What was I expecting?
我就坐在那里，面对一个 80 多岁还在讲那种调情笑话的人，而我在向他询问妇女运动。我期待什么呢？
I am sympathetic to any woman's movement. I do a joke on it. Because it's such a big laugh that I close my act on it.
我对任何妇女运动都抱有同情心。我为此讲了一个笑话。因为它效果太好，我以它作为演出的结尾。
"It's nice to be here in Honolulu. And I tell you, women are really coming to the fore in this world." I said, "It's wonderful. I'm so happy because we pushed them around long enough, kept them down. In fact, I remember a friend of mine saying to his wife, 'How could you be so incredibly beautiful and so incredibly stupid?' And she said, 'It's God's will.' He says, 'What do you mean?' She says, 'Well, he made me incredibly beautiful, so you would be attracted to me, and made me incredibly stupid, so I'd be attracted to you.'" Well, they die. And I'd say, "That's for the ladies. Thank you. God bless you. Good-bye." I close my act with that.
“很高兴来到火奴鲁鲁。我告诉你们，女性在这个世界上真正开始崭露头角了。”我说，“这太棒了，我很高兴，因为我们推开她们太久了，打压她们。事实上，我记得我有个朋友对他妻子说：‘你怎么能如此美丽又如此愚蠢？’她说：‘这是上帝的旨意。’他说：‘你什么意思？’她说：‘嗯，他让我如此美丽，所以你会被我吸引；让我如此愚蠢，所以我会被你吸引。’”好吧，她们大笑。我会说，“那是为女士们准备的。谢谢。上帝保佑你们。再见。”我以那个结束我的演出。
He was friends with so many presidents, it was like being friends with Bob Hope came with the job. He played golf with Eisenhower, Nixon, Ford, George Bush senior. President Kennedy had him over to the White House to discuss jokes. LBJ presented him with a Medal of Freedom. Friends since the '40s, he and Ronald Reagan had an annual tradition of celebrating New Year's at Walter Annenberg's in Palm Springs.
他是那么多总统的朋友，就像和鲍勃·霍普做朋友是工作的一部分一样。他和艾森豪威尔、尼克松、福特、老布什打过高尔夫球。肯尼迪总统请他去白宫讨论笑话。林登·约翰逊授予他自由勋章。自 40 年代就是朋友，他和罗纳德·里根有个每年在棕榈泉瓦尔特·安嫩伯格家中庆祝新年的传统。
Right around the time we met, the Iran-Contra scandal was just beginning to break, and Hope was struggling with how he was going to address the topic of the day without hurting his old pal's feelings. At one point, he did his Iran-Contra bit for me.
就在我们见面的时候，“伊朗门”丑闻刚开始爆发，霍普正在挣扎着如何处理这个当天的话题而不伤及他老伙计的感情。有一次，他为我表演了他的“伊朗门”片段。
I said, "I don't know whether I want to go back to the States because I hate it when our foreign policy is funnier than I am." "And Congress is really upset because, you know, they get mad when people screw things up, and they don't have anything to do with it." I said, "I don't know who the White House aides were. It was either Curly, Larry or Moe." "And I can't understand selling arms to Iran," I said. "That's like Johnny Carson giving jokes to Joan Rivers."
我说：“我不知道是否想回美国，因为我讨厌我们的外交政策比我更搞笑。”“而且国会真的心烦意乱，因为你知道，当人们把事情搞砸了，而他们却没参与其中时，他们会很生气。”我说，“我不知道白宫助手是谁。不是库尔、拉里就是莫。”“而且我不理解向伊朗出售武器，”我说。“那就像约翰尼·卡森给琼·里弗斯提供笑话一样。”
Well, that doesn't hurt anybody. And it's all front page. So you have to go that way. That's the way I go.
嗯，那不会伤害任何人。而且全是头版头条。所以你必须朝那个方向走。这就是我的路子。
Hope has always been identified more with the right than the left. It was Republicans, never Democrats, who invited him to sleep in the Lincoln bedroom. But on that day, when I brought up politics, he classified himself as nonpartisan. A leaner, I think he called himself, someone who leans in the direction of whomever is currently in power.
霍普一直被认为更倾向于右派而非左派。是共和党人，而不是民主党人，邀请他去林肯卧室睡觉。但在那天，当我提到政治时，他将自己归类为“非党派”。我想他称自己为一个倾斜者，一个倾向于任何目前掌权者的人。
Whether he was a leaner or not, his image as a fence straddler ended in 1963 with the Vietnam War. He was forced to make a political choice, and whichever choice he made, it wasn't going to sit well with the other side. If he decided to go to Vietnam to entertain the troops, he was supporting an unpopular war. But if he decided to stay home, he risked breaking a tradition and disrupting a so-far harmonious relationship with a government who'd help make him an American icon. Well, you may remember what he decided.
不管他是不是倾斜者，他作为篱笆墙头草的形象在 1963 年随着越南战争结束了。他被迫做出政治选择，无论他做出什么选择，另一方都不会满意。如果他决定去越南慰问部队，他就是在支持一场不得人心的战争。但如果他决定待在家里，他就要冒着打破传统和破坏与一个曾帮助他成为美国偶像的政府之间和谐关系的风险。好吧，你可能还记得他决定了什么。
From Shemya Island in the Aleutians, from Yokota, Japan, and from Camp Casey, and Osan in Korea--
来自阿留申群岛的谢米亚岛，来自日本横田，以及凯西营和韩国乌山——
In the end, Hope did nine Christmas tours in Vietnam. And each of those shows, he taped, produced, and sold to NBC as television specials.
最终，霍普在越南进行了九次圣诞巡演。每一场演出，他都录制、制作并作为电视特别节目卖给了 NBC。
From Udorn, U-Tapao, and Nam Phong in Thailand, and from Tan Son Nhut Air Base in Vietnam, it's the Bob Hope Christmas special starring Redd Foxx, Lola Falana--
来自乌隆、乌塔堡和泰国的纳姆蓬，以及越南新山一空军基地，这是鲍勃·霍普圣诞特别节目，由雷德·福克斯、萝拉·法拉娜主演——
For the first time, he began generating criticism. Though there were still cheering crowds, there were plenty of times where the men booed Bob Hope and gave him the finger. In an era of Jimi Hendrix and pot smoking, picture long-haired troops without shirts, smoking cigarettes, and drinking beer, being treated to golf jokes, big band music, and a juggler.
这是他第一次产生争议。尽管仍然有欢呼的群众，但有很多时候，士兵们对着鲍勃·霍普发出嘘声并向他竖起中指。在吉米·亨德里克斯和抽大麻的时代，想象一下赤裸上身、抽烟喝酒、留着长发的大兵们，被强行要求欣赏高尔夫笑话、大乐队音乐和一个玩杂耍的人。
In 1980, in Rolling Stone magazine, writer Timothy White quoted servicemen who claimed that attendance was mandatory, that they were a captive audience, that the scantily clad showgirls that had so delighted GIs in the past now just seemed like PG-rated strippers to the men, women who they could look at, but couldn't touch.
1980 年，《滚石》杂志的作者蒂莫西·怀特援引军人的话说，出席是强制性的，他们是“被俘虏的观众”，过去让大兵们大悦的衣着暴露的舞女，现在在男人们眼中看来就像是 PG 级的脱衣舞女，她们是他们可以看但不能碰的女人。
Hello. I'm Miss Kansas, Cindy Lee Sikes. Merry Christmas. Oh, I'm 18, and I won the swimsuit contest in the Miss America Pageant.
你好。我是堪萨斯小姐，辛迪·李·赛克斯。圣诞快乐。哦，我 18 岁，我赢得了美国小姐选美大赛的泳装比赛。
[CHEERS AND WHISTLES]
[欢呼和口哨声]
In this footage, things don't seem so wholesome anymore. Each girl is dressed in a spangley leotard, and the men surge forward like they're going to devour them.
在这些录像中，事情看起来不再那么纯洁了。每个女孩都穿着亮晶晶的紧身衣，男人们像要吞噬她们一样冲上前去。
Hi y'all. I'm Melanie. I'm Miss Georgia World. Anybody from Georgia?
大家好。我是梅兰妮。我是佐治亚世界小姐。有佐治亚来的吗？
[CHEERS AND WHISTLES]
[欢呼和口哨声]
Any of y'all like to try a little of our southern comfort?
你们有人想尝尝我们的南方舒适吗？
[CHEERS AND WHISTLES]
[欢呼和口哨声]
Next, two young blondes are on stage with Bob Hope.
接下来，两个年轻的金发女郎和鲍勃·霍普在舞台上。
Hi, I'm Tricia Barnstable from Louisville, Kentucky.
嗨，我是来自肯塔基州路易斯维尔的特里西娅·巴恩斯特布尔。
[CHEERS AND WHISTLES]
[欢呼和口哨声]
And I'm Cyb Barnstable, her twin sister. And we just want to know if there's anybody out there who thinks they can handle two.
我是赛布·巴恩斯特布尔，她的双胞胎姐姐。我们只想知道外面有没有人认为他们能应付得了一对。
[CHEERS AND WHISTLES]
[欢呼和口哨声]
Back home, it almost seemed like Bob Hope was blind to the politics of what he was doing and out of touch. There's an incredible quote from Marlon Brando from an interview in Playboy magazine. Brando called Hope "an applause junky." He said, "Bob Hope will go to the opening of a phone booth in a gas station in Anaheim provided they have a camera and three people there. He'll go the opening of a market and receive an award." Brando said, "It didn't bother him at all to work the Vietnam War. Oh, he took that in his stride. He did his World War Two and Korean War act-- our boys, and all that. He's a pathetic guy."
在家里，鲍勃·霍普似乎对他所做之事的政治性视而不见，与时代脱节。马龙·白兰度在《花花公子》杂志的一次采访中有一段惊人的引述。白兰度称霍普为“掌声瘾君子”。他说：“鲍勃·霍普会去阿纳海姆加油站电话亭的开幕式，只要那里有摄像机和三个人。他会去市场的开幕式并领取奖项。”白兰度说，“他在越南战争期间工作根本没让他困扰。哦，他泰然自若地接受了。他表演他的二战和朝鲜战争节目——我们的男孩，等等。他是个可悲的家伙。”
The criticism after Vietnam truly stunned Bob Hope. For years, he was seen as a good ambassador, agendaless, flying around the world representing our country. He hadn't changed anything, but somehow, he'd become a bane to the anti-war movement, a militarist, controversial. It didn't make any sense to him.
越战后的批评让鲍勃·霍普感到震惊。多年来，他被视为一名出色的外交大使，无党派，飞往世界各地代表我们的国家。他没有改变任何事情，但不知何故，他成了反战运动的克星，一个好战分子，一个有争议的人物。这对他来说毫无意义。
We weren't carrying bullets. We were carrying laughs. And I wasn't the only one going. Everybody went to Vietnam, Jimmy Stewart and his wife, Roy Rogers, John Wayne, Charlton Heston, Johnny Grant. But on account of me getting all the television coverage and doing that show, they all got the feeling, they said, "Hey, he's doing this show, that's a commercial show," and so on and so on and so on. And anybody that would deny those kids the right to have a show like we brought them, well, you felt kind of sorry for those people. Because they couldn't have been very patriotic.
我们没带子弹。我们带的是笑声。去越南的不止我一个，吉米·斯图尔特和他的妻子、罗伊·罗杰斯、约翰·韦恩、查尔顿·赫斯顿、约翰尼·格兰特。但由于我获得了所有的电视报道并做了那个节目，他们都有了这种感觉，他们说：“嘿，他在做那个节目，那是商业节目，”等等等等。任何拒绝给那些孩子提供我们带给他们的那种演出权利的人，嗯，你会为那些人感到遗憾。因为他们不可能非常爱国。
I had a couple of people that called me a warmonger. And I gave it to the FBI and the sheriff here. And they found these guys over in Santa Monica Boulevard, and they chased them out of the town.
有几个人打电话骂我是战争贩子。我把它交给了 FBI 和这儿的警长。他们在那儿圣莫尼卡大道上找到了这些人，并把他们赶出了城。
Who were the people?
那些人是谁？
They were some bums that were probably guys that were defectors or something. A kid walked up to me out here in Van Nuys-- I was in an ice cream store-- went out to my car. And a kid walked up to the car and said, "Hey, is it true that you took guns to Vietnam?" I said, "Where'd you hear that?" He said, "Oh, I read that somewhere." And I said, "Let me tell you something, son." I said, "I took laughs to Vietnam." I said, "Did you ever see my show?"
他们是一些无赖，可能是叛逃者之类的。一个孩子走过来找我——我在冰淇淋店——走回我的车。一个孩子走上车说：“嘿，你带枪去越南是真的吗？”我说：“你从哪儿听说的？”他说：“哦，我在某处读到的。”我说：“让我告诉你一件事，孩子。”我说：“我带的是笑声去了越南。”我说：“你看过我的节目吗？”
He might have known that the politics of war would lead him down this road eventually. No one could deny that in his career with the USO, Bob Hope faced hardships and acted out of a sense of altruism and patriotism. But it's also clear that there was another side to it all. He'd figured out a way to use international conflict as a marketing tool for his reputation and career. And there's nothing wrong with that. It just seems wrong to cry foul when people stop laughing.
他可能早已知道战争的政治性最终会将他带向这条路。没人能否认，在他在 USO 的职业生涯中，鲍勃·霍普面临艰辛，并出于利他主义和爱国主义行动。但同样清楚的是，这一切还有另一面。他找到了将国际冲突作为他声誉和职业生涯营销工具的方法。这没什么错。只是在人们停止笑的时候喊“冤”似乎就不对了。
Margy Rochlin in Los Angeles.
在洛杉矶的玛吉·罗克林。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who has this message for his rebel troops.
WBEZ 的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他给他的反叛部队传达了这样一个信息。
Our house has seven doors. All are green except one.
我们的房子有七扇门。全都是绿色的，除了其中一扇。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台（PRI）。